Hey Up Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich. This is Radiolab.
And today today we are doing our black box, our yeah. And a black box is a,
it's a thing. It's a box that when something goes in, you can see what that is.
Something comes out, which is different and you can see that,
but you do not know what's going on in the middle. It's a mystery. I love it.
There's the, shall we go inside of course. And uh,
our next and final black box comes from our producer Molly Webster.
And it begins into the butter plier rain forest.
Oh.
So that you can see the butterflies that are flying. In fact,
so a few days ago I was in Gainesville,
Florida at the Florida Museum of natural history where they have a rainforest.
It's what about three stories tall?
It's like got a top that's all wrapped in a net.
And then it was covered in butterflies. Oh my gosh. There's so many thousands.
Yes. So these are highly corneas. Butterfly. That's the Andre Circle.
I've thought of looking at butterflies when I was six years old and I have never
grew up. He was my guide on the, you're on the,
this leap even see an all butter phone.
One wing is like the size of my palm.
So there were red ones like in the yellow one blue ones. Striped ones. Is that,
is that a monarch? Yes.
Which don't step on this butterfly because it's like a Dr Sushi and land of
butterflies. But I was there to look at the moment right before,
before they become butterflies,
which remains one of the most mysterious black boxes in nature.
What I'm talking about is something called the Chrysalis. The chrysalis.
Just tobacco. Yeah.
At a certain point in all caterpillars lives after they've eaten a lot of
leaves, they hit a certain weight that is coded in that gene.
As their final weight hormones start pumping,
some genetics turn on and it starts growing a little shell.
That's the Chrysalis. And inside that Chrysalis, as we know,
a Catholic pillar becomes a butterfly, a moth.
Um,
and this is a mystery. What do you think happens inside the Chrysalis?
I think that actually, I've never thought about it to be honest. I don't know.
I don't, I don't understand how it works. Not many people have.
Are you like surprised that you actually don't know? Yeah, I'm surprised.
I thought like I knew and I don't, those are folks I met at the museum.
They hold up now that I've thought about it for a second,
isn't it simply that um, the caterpillar is inside the shell.
It sort of snuggles up and then it grows a wing off of his right side and then
off its left side and it just pops wings out. No,
that is actually what I thought. But that's not right at all.
[inaudible]
one, why are some days located on three floors? Because here's the thing.
So now we're going into the bowels of the building.
When you take one of those little black boxes and you slice it open over the
booth. Yes. Which Andre was nice enough to do for me. Sorry.
Even though he loves these guys, he took a tiny little Chrysalis. Okay.
It's a ball and inch long,
which a caterpillar had just gotten into one day ago and he slowly began to cut
taking our tweezer like scissors through the outer layer of the Chrysalis until
she pupil
who?
Oh my gosh, what? No, it was like there was no caterpillar bear.
What do you mean there's no head. There were no legs. There was no antenna,
no spiky spine. It's like hail, white,
yellow. It's very liquidy what was there.
Then basically just goose,
just like a runny goopy goo looks like snot.
All you have to do is give it like a little [inaudible]
please, and then just went, oh, oh,
it is bullshit. Exploded. It exploded it.
I think he looked shocked to wait. I don't understand.
Where did the Caterpillar go?
It seems like once the caterpillar gets into its shell, it's sort of just melts
its head, legs on the abdomen.
They all just dissolve muscles themselves, just sorta like
dissolve away into individual muscle cells and some of the cells rupture and so
their incise, the amino acids, the proteins,
those all go floating out into space where you're sitting that caterpillar just
becomes like a soup of cells. Yeah. And yet somehow
magically be transformed
on a butterfly or a moth.
[inaudible]
well, how does that happen? That question, that question is the big fat,
metaphysical, quasi religious semi mystical,
philosophical question that people have been asking for ever.
Yeah. So one of the big arguments that was taking place,
this is Matthew Cobb,
he's a biologist and a historian and he says back in the 16 hundreds when
naturalists saw that Goo, they just thought, oh, well,
clearly what's happening is that the caterpillar goes into the Chrysalis and
then it actually dies,
totally dies and out of its burial cloth is going to come the new life,
this beautiful and completely new creature, death as it were,
and then a kind of resurrection.
That's Phillip Clayton.
He's a philosopher from the Claremont School of theology,
and he says it from the beginning,
people thought about and wrote about metamorphosis as a kind of spiritual ascent
, said somewhere in the new testament, behold the old has passed away.
The new has surely come.
Basically people saw the caterpillar as a symbol of art,
lowly earthbound, Lazy bodies, right?
And then the butterfly was sort of casting away all of that.
And it represented our soul up in heaven,
sort of in its most perfect form.
Nevermind that butterflies actually like to eat feces and urine and other on the
substances according to Andre. Sounds tasty.
Nevermind that the metaphor is like inspiring at some level, right?
Because you think, oh, I've got all,
I'm going to just become more a more perfect version of myself, right? Yeah.
Yeah.
But then the converse side of that is you cut open a Chrysalis and it looks like
a whole bunch of Goo and you think it a hell of a lot of change.
So the thing is is that this transformation,
either of the butterfly or of my soul seems so dramatic,
so miraculous that it made some people think like, Geez,
if you're going to go to heaven in the process transformed that much,
is it even you up there? It still has to be you that makes it to heaven.
You can't change too much otherwise,
like someone else will be up there enjoying your afterlife.
So certain memories and elements of your identity have to continue just not all
the elements. I'm so intrigued by that because I also think like
what I'm like, what when you undergo such a transformation,
what, what do they think carries through? That's a really interesting question.
Cleaning out the poop and throwing away the the moldy leaves.
You have a lot of time to think which brings us to Martha Weiss.
I am an associate professor of biology at Georgetown University.
She got to thinking about this question in more concrete terms. Okay,
so she did an experiment.
What we did was we took a big green caterpillar and we did something that was
not entirely nice. She put them in a box,
filled it with a nasty odor, and it's the odor,
like an odor of a plant or it's actually a plant based odor,
but it's smells kind of like a nail Polish remover. In any case,
she gassed him with this nasty smell and then once they could smell the odor,
then we gave them a zip. Is that just like a Zap?
Just a Zip Zap, I think 10 seconds of Zap, 10 seconds.
And they did this over and over. Odor, Zap, odor, Zap, Odell.
Eventually most of these caterpillars learn to hate the smell.
Every time they get a whiff, they head in the opposite direction. Okay,
so then we let them pupate meaning the caterpillar changes into its shell and
Oregon's dissolve muscles. Mel, you get this cataclysmic, catastrophic,
chaotic change.
And then one month later the moth emerges and now we're with the drum roll.
We're ready for the drum roll.
They give the moths a width. Okay. And the moths hate the smell.
I mean normally Mosto care about the smell at all.
It's like 50 50 but these moths hated it. Somehow I'm confused.
What does that mean? That means a memory made it through the Goo.
Oh, and it came out the other side. Oh, what's your,
what's your feeling like coming out of this? My feeling is, wow.
[inaudible]
I think it's amazing that a caterpillar can have an experience go into its
Chrysalis,
five weeks pass emerge as a seemingly different organism and that it still can
recall experiences that happened to it when it was a caterpillar.
[inaudible]
and how does that happen? The answer to this question is we do not know, but,
but out there floating in that sea of Goo is actually a tiny little spec of
brain. Some of the brain is dissolved away,
but there's this like microscopic fragment that has made it through and Martha
suspects that nestled into that fragment is this memory. Oh,
it's like a little boop, like a little beacon.
And it turns out there are others too.
There's a speck of gut, some nerves,
some muscle. It's not as Gooey as it seems. God, it's like,
it's like I can't help wondering,
what does the butterfly know about its caterpillar life?
Like it knows this one tiny thing. But how much else does it know?
It crawled that it has no answers that question.
But Martha says that these types of questions like come up all the time.
In fact, one of our colleagues, and I was talking to Doug the other day,
and he said that he had gotten an email from a guy who was, uh,
uh, I'm not exactly sure what flavor of Christian, but had,
but he,
he had gone into the whole resurrection thing and he felt like this was,
you know,
when he ascended that he wondered if he would then be able to remember his life
on earth.
[inaudible]
well, here's the answer. What answer? Well, the answer,
the answer to the question about what carries through the continuity question.
Oh, right, yes. And memory carries through, which is freaking cool.
I gotta say, and it's freaking cool, but there's a little more freaking cool.
All right. And that is that there's actually a continuity,
but it goes in the reverse direction. What does that even mean? Well,
Matthew Cop told me the story about this guy,
this a 17th century man who I never had never heard of John. Uh,
his name's written Sua Madame, but it's probably more pronounced as from a dump.
Fama dumb. That's yawns farmer dom,
a Dutch microscopist from the 16 hundreds.
He was definitely the first to do some very clear dissections of the Chrysalis
and the Caterpillar.
And one day in Paris in front of this crowd of assembled worthies be wigged and
a bit stocking. He gets a fat white caterpillar,
gets a scalpel or a tiny little thin bit of glass and he, it,
he just opens it up at the back along its back along line.
And what he sees inside or what he can show them is that in fact there are some
of the structures of the future, a butterfly, its wings,
its antennae,
and even its legs that are actually already formed even before PW patient takes
place,
peel back the skin of a caterpillar.
And beneath that you see the uh, new,
the new creature hidden. Absolutely. So bizarre.
It's like,
it's like if you were to skin me and there's my 70 year old self is inside of me
or something.
Wait, the, the, and the wings also survived the Goo. Yeah.
So it's like a caterpillar will actually start to grow little tiny adult parts
that are super thin and transparent and it just keeps them tightly rolled up and
hidden up against the edges of the Chrysalis.
But they don't actually ever go through the Gu or become the goo.
What he'd then shown was, you know what? This isn't about death.
This isn't about decay. This is actually about transformation.
[inaudible]
I dunno. It's kind of eerie.
Like it's not just what Ami carries forward into the future.
It's like,
what of my future self is in me right now?
[inaudible] [inaudible] I am all
[inaudible].
Uh,
I am
thanks to our producers, the Sour Tim Howard, Molly Webster, Jesse Cox,
and thanks to you guys for listening. Yeah.